so when I was in college I fell in love
with a boy who was mean to me
um oh God yeah yeah you know what we've
all done that yeah well he broke up with
me and he said that I was too ambitious
and wanted too many things and I would
end up alone and lonely and so I got
really mad and then I was like fine I'm
gonna figure out all the things I'm
going to do to make him Rue the day that
he was mean to me and so I this was now
I'm old I'm 49. so I'm going to be 48
we're right next to each other so you'll
appreciate this this was before Excel
this is when it was Lotus one two three
right okay you had to go to the computer
lab because owning a computer meant that
you could buy the world right I went to
the computer lab at Spelman and I did a
spreadsheet and I laid out all the
things I was going to accomplish in all
the ways I was going to just be
fantastic and magnificent and I don't
know if he's ever going to see it but
I'm I'm doing okay I'm I'm doing okay on
my Sprite